hi I want to start by thanking the
organizers for bringing us all together
it's been a very fun workshop so what
I'm going to talk about today is a part
of a book I'm working on called bit by
bit social research for the digital age
and I think of the book as being for
social scientists that want to do more
data science and data scientists I want
to do more social science so I see these
as two very interesting and exciting
communities that are not really in as
much contact with each other as they
could be and should be and I think this
is a goal that many of us in the room
share another way to think about what
I'm trying to do and I think what many
of us are trying to do is to push this
intellectual movement through the hype
cycle so when this is when a new
technology is introduced this is a sort
of empirical pattern that often occurs
this is from some research by Gardner
which is a consulting company so the
x-axis here is time the y-axis I think
could be called excitement initially
something happens everyone gets very
excited and they say Oh big data is
going to solve every problem in the
world then people realize actually it's
not everything that people claim and
they move into this trough of
disillusionment and then eventually over
time people realize no actually this is
pretty good this has real serious
implications they weren't quite as good
as we thought at the beginning but they
definitely weren't as bad as we thought
in the middle and so I think different
people in the computational social
science community are at different
stages along this curve and so one of
the things I think I want to try to do
with my book is to push down this peak
of inflated expectations pull up the
trough and then get to here as quickly
as possible and so implicit in this
framing is definitely an argument that
this is a real thing like I think in the
end there is this plateau of
productivity here where this becomes a
normal part of the way we advance social
science so the book has seven chapters
and rather than organizing them around
pacific data sources like here's how to
do it with Twitter and here's how to do
with Facebook I tried to organize it in
a different way because my expectation
is that a lot of the data sources that
exist today will not be here five years
from now or 10 years from now so when I
started doing this kind of research
everyone was super excited about virtual
worlds like Second Life some of you may
remember second life that was a big
thing not here anymore so we need a more
timeless way to think about how to
organize this research and so I think
they're really four main research
designs there's observed data there's
data we basically just watch people's
behavior this is most of the data that
people are using now there's asking
people questions there's manipulating
their environment to run experiments and
then there's actually actively
collaborating with them so this is like
crowd sourcing and citizen science and
so generally most of the research is of
this type now but I argue in the book
that as we move down this as we have
more interaction with the participants
in more control over their environment
we can actually learn much much more
then there's a chapter about ethics and
a chapter about the future so what I'm
going to talk about today is the survey
part of this so this may seem initially
like the least interesting part of the
book because generally people aren't
excited about surveys but I'm going to
try to convince you that this is not in
any way the least interesting part okay
so one question that you might have is
but why should I care about surveys in
the digital age so let me even actually
take a step back why should I care about
surveys at all so I'm a sociologist and
most of what we know in sociology and
quantitative sociology comes through
surveys and I would say it's a similar
statement about political science and
maybe some of the other social sciences
as well so this is a fundamental part of
how we learn about the world and it's a
part that no one really likes so survey
researchers are not very satisfied with
the properties of surveys and
participants are definitely not
satisfied with the experience of being
in a servant I met all of you have been
in surveys and I would guess most of you
hated the
experience so we have this really kind
of fundamental measurement technology
that powers a lot of what we do and it
could be a lot better let's say it like
that so then to extend the question why
should we care about it in the digital
age so some people are saying oh we have
all this automatically collected data
we're going to not need to ask people
questions anymore and I think that's
just fundamentally wrong and so when I
see a lot of this a lot of the data
people are using is what some people
call digital exhaust it's like leftover
stuff that people throw off during the
course of their daily life and when I
look at that what I see is a bunch of
like debris so some people think of this
stuff they use a metaphor of like oh
it's like a microscope or it's like a
telescope I think it's just like
leftover garbage so this is business up
obviously it's an aesthetic taste some
but I'm going to argue a little more
seriously about why I think this is true
so all this data on Twitter it's big and
shiny and new but it has a lot of the
same characteristics as stuff you find
in an archaeological site so you need to
think about why is some data preserved
and not other data and you need to think
about even given an infinite number of
pottery shards actually taking those and
then making inference to what is
happening in a complex society as a
whole nother step of inference that is
very challenging so now I'm going to
make this a little more specific why I
think we'll always need to ask even in
the age of digital exhaust so I'm not
saying that we will continue to ask in
the same way as we have in the past how
we will ask will change but we will
always need to ask so first is the
inherent limitations of digital exhaust
so one way I sort of think about this
when I was in high school there is this
company called FUBU that may close its
call for us by us and digital exhaust is
not for us and not by us and so here I'm
thinking of researchers so the ways
companies collect their data is in the
service of those companies it's not and
it turns out that that's not usually the
kinds of things researchers aren't
resident so for example my cell phone
company can say what percentage of their
calls everyday are between people whose
credit card number ends in nine if
that's something they have data to do
they cannot say what percentage of phone
calls are between people of a different
race or a different level of education a
lot of things that as a sociologist I
would be really interested and they
potentially have the capability of
giving us this real-time measure of
social segregation but they're never
going to do that because they don't want
to know I would guess they don't want to
know their customers race and education
and social class and so on they
definitely want to know their credit
card number so I think fundamentally
there are limits to how we can repurpose
this data that was not created for
research it was created for helping
these companies do whatever they're
doing sometimes we can repurpose it
we've seen I'll actually a lot of clever
examples of this today but I think
fundamentally that's limited also even
given an infinite amount of data about
people's behavior it's harder to learn
about internal states so you know
sociologists sometimes make a
distinction between these two we can
know everything that you're doing and
it's hard to know things that are
happening inside of your head like your
attitudes and the knowledge that you
have in your emotions and so on so for
example you know an example that we
frequently asked in surveys is something
like do you approve of how President
Obama is doing so that's an internal
state and the best way to estimate that
internal state is often to ask people
and then finally there's an
inaccessibility of this digital exhaust
and this is a problem I think people are
not as sensitive to as they could be so
even if the all the digital exhausts in
the world exists if researchers don't
have access to it it doesn't really
matter and I think there are fundamental
limitations to how much this digital
exhaust can be shared so I worked for a
while at Microsoft and I didn't really
appreciate this until I work there it's
like not that these companies are bad
and don't want to share their data with
research it's like they're real legal
and business barriers to actually this
data leaving these companies so
imagine if there's a data leak at let's
say Facebook that is really like a
existential threat to their business
right because if people don't trust
Facebook with their data they're going
to stop putting data into it the ads are
going to do worse and so on so like
their real fundamental limitations to
research or access to this data so i
think for these kinds of reasons we're
always going to need to ask people how
we ask is going to change but we're
always going to need to ask some so
sometimes people think of surveys and
like that you know digital exhausted
kind of replace service that they're
sort of substitutes for each other but
actually I really think of them much
more as compliments so just like peanut
butter and jelly are much better
together I think surveys and digital
exhaust actually work really really well
together because they have different
strengths and weaknesses and so as there
is more and more digital exhaust I think
there's going to be increasing demand
for more and more service if we can
figure out how to do them appropriately
in the new environment okay so now I
want to get back to sort of the title of
the talk which is about the third era of
survey research which is I think a
potentially big and important orienting
problem we've talked a lot about problem
driven research so here's my explanation
for what a good problem is but to
understand it we have to understand a
little bit more about the history of
survey research so surveys as we know
them today sort of originated around
1930 and during the first year of survey
research which was around sort of ends
around the 60s and 70s sampling was done
with area probability sampling and
interviews were done face-to-face so
basically people would sample different
neighborhoods and they would send
interviewers into those neighborhoods to
go and interview people and then in the
60s in developed countries people said
hey there's a lot of landline telephones
like how be great if we could do surveys
over the telephone so this is big
technical technological change in the
world and then researchers created this
second error of survey research so this
is the research the era that were
somewhat in now and it's characterized
by random digit dial probability sim
and telephone interviews and so this
transition from the first era to the
second area era was very contested took
a lot of work to get this resolved but
eventually we got a resolve because the
advantages of this second error approach
were really great so now the second
error approach is breaking down so this
is a what discuss frequently in the
social science community I'm just
basically going to assert that this is
not going to work anymore it's it's the
long-term trends are very clear and this
is not just a problem that academics
feel governments around the world have
official statistics offices all of them
are running into this problem as well so
like the National Academy had a recent
report about this like this is a big
problem in the world not just our
problem so what is the third era of
survey research going to look like so
this now we're sort of we're kind of in
the process of creating it now and so
this is sort of my speculation for what
it will look like so first sampling will
become dominated by non-probability
sampling so this will be quite a big
change that people find very frustrating
also interviews will no longer be
administered by humans will have much
more computer administered interviews
and then there's going to be a third
characteristic that's different from the
first two eras which is the how surveys
relate to other things in the data
environment so right now most surveys
are standalone things but as the amount
of data that exists in the world
increases much more you're going to see
surveys linked to other sources of data
they're really big advantages to
combining things and by this linking I
don't just mean like strict record
linkage at the individual level I would
include things like Google Flu Trends in
this so Google Flu Trends takes the CDC
influenza surveillance data and the
Google search data to combine them in a
way that produces estimates as
properties that neither of these data
sets has individually
so this is what I would propose as a
problem so creating this third era of
survey research so this is a something
that has many of the properties that
we've discussed I'll come back to it at
the end and what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to talk about one specific
aspect of this I'm going to talk about
this part of the third era of Survey
Research moving towards computer and
ministered interviews which is again
maybe the apparently least exciting
aspect of this so right this seems kind
of like these two seem like very
interesting kind of statistical
challenges and this actually is also
very interesting statistical and
conceptual challenge and that so I'm
going to talk about okay so most surveys
now are admitted many surveys now are
administered by human someone calls you
up or someone comes to your house and
ask you a bunch of questions and that is
very expensive and that also has certain
limitations in terms of you have to they
can only happen when both people are in
the same place or so as we move towards
computer administrative interviews cost
will come down and flexibility will
increase so what this is going to do is
it's going to enable us to do stuff that
we haven't done before which is great so
it's not just that we want to take what
we've done before and put it on a
computer is we want to also do new stuff
that we couldn't do before and then
second it's going to require certain
changes so surveys are a terrible user
experience the people don't like filling
out surveys and it's going to get harder
and harder to induce people to answer
our surveys unless we make them a better
experience and so when there's a human
administering the survey there's
something that's sort of keeping you
engaged in the process as that human
disappears we have to do different kinds
of design to keep people involved and
engaged so it's going to require change
and it's going to enable change and so
what I'm going to tell you about now is
a project I've done that this is joint
work with Karen levy that was inspired
by this website kitten war calm
so if you go to kitten wore this is what
you will see please don't go to get more
now because you won't hear anything else
I say so you click on one of these
kittens and then another pair of kitten
shows up and you click again and you
click again and again again and before
you know it you spent 20 minutes
clicking on kittens so in addition to
being a fun way to spend time there's
something actually much deeper happening
here so if you click to see the
winningest kittens this is what you see
it's pretty cute i would say in my
opinion as a scientist this is a pretty
cute and if you click to see the
losingest kittens this is what you say
very different so let's go back here for
one second so what you've seen is that
this very simple and enjoyable voting
mechanism is able to detect this very
real social signal the other thing
that's amazing about this to me is that
all of these kittens were uploaded by
users so user-generated content is a
very common thing on the web but a very
rare thing in surveys right so one of
the great things about this is that
kitten war is a system to find the
cutest cat anywhere in the cat picture
anywhere in the world even if it's not
something that i knew about ahead of
time as a researcher even if it's not in
a book in the library so in essence
kitten more really solves a fundamental
problem with social data collection and
that is we underlying a lot of the ways
we collect data there's this tension
between quantify ability and openness so
in the one hand we have methods like
surveys that are very good at
quantifying large amounts of information
but surveys are fundamentally closed so
you write all the questions and you
write all the answers so anyone has ever
written the survey before how's this
fear of like oh maybe I'm not asking the
right question or I haven't included the
right answer choices so they're very
constrained in it it's very hard to
learn something new new in a survey so
for that that's a very known problem and
for that reason social scientists also
have methods like interviews focus
groups and ethnography that are much
more open to new information but those
methods struggle also
because they're slow and expensive and
hard to quantify and so what this is
about is trying to create a hybrid that
combines the quantify ability of surveys
with the openness of interviews we call
this wiki surveys sort of inspired by
Wikipedia so just like Wikipedia evolves
over time based on user input imagine if
you had a survey that evolved over time
based on user input okay so we thought
okay let's try to think about what this
would look like and more generally let's
try to think about what would a survey
that was really designed for a digital
environment look like so most of the
you've probably all been in web service
and I would argue that none of you have
been in a real web survey so what you've
been in is a face-to-face survey that's
put on the web if you print it out the
last survey monkey survey that you were
in you could give that to an interviewer
who would go door-to-door and just ask
people questions so what's happened is
people have just transferred the way
we've done things before into this new
medium and that's not really taking
advantage of its opportunities it's like
if you have a radio soap opera and then
you put a TV camera in front of it and
then you say you have a TV soap opera
but you don't you have radio soap opera
put on TV and I think we have
face-to-face surveys put on the web so
what would a real web survey look like
and so for this we looked at a lot of
online information aggregation systems
things like Wikipedia and we try to
think about some general properties that
they have so if we sort of try to take
all the ideas of survey research and all
the ideas of Wikipedia and put them
together this is kind of what we came up
with these three general properties so
one is wiki surveys should be greedy and
what I mean by greedy is the following
they should collect as much or as little
information as each person is willing to
provide and this differs fundamentally
from the way surveys work now so if you
look at a lot of online systems you'll
see a property like this so this is a
rank order plot so this here is the
person the x axis is the contributors by
rank the y-axis is the amount that they
contribute so this is the purse
and that contributes the most to
Wikipedia they contribute lots of
information and then there's a lot of
people who contribute a little bit of
information so this sometimes called the
fat head and the long tail and part of
what makes Wikipedia magical is that it
can harvest all that information so if
you want to spend 80 hours a week
contributing to Wikipedia great if you
want to add a comma once a month great
and that differs fundamentally from how
social scientists usually collect their
data so in surveys we collect a fixed
amount of information per person if
someone comes to you and says i love
your survey i want to do it a hundred
times it's so it's funny because like no
one would do that because surveys are
such an awful experience but if people
are really interested and want to help
you more we don't let them do that and
if someone comes to you and says oh
you're what you're doing is okay i'll
give you one minute we said no you can't
do that that creates item non-response
so we're dropping off all these
potential light contributors to so to
put this back into the context of
wikipedia if they allow 10 and only 10
edits per person they would lose about
ninety-five percent of their edits so
enormous amounts of information in the
fat head and the long tail that we want
to capture in these wiki surveys second
we want them to be collaborative so
rather than the idea of a researcher
creates the instrument we want to have
the participants also playing a role in
creating the instrument and this is
going to be key for us to actually
learning new things and then finally we
want the procedure to be adaptive and so
what I mean by adaptive is we want to
use all the information that we have at
any moment to only ask people the next
question that's the most valuable for us
so if we took our participants time
seriously and treated as a valuable
resource we would only want to ask them
the most important questions and the way
surveys work right now is all the
questions are fixed in advance and you
can't change them once you start so by
the time the order is fixed so but by
the time if you're going to do a
thousand interviews by the time you've
done 500 you actually know much more
than you knew at the beginning that
information is basically off limits
the way we do surveys now so just one
thing collaborative and adaptive seemed
to be similar but I want to clarify
collaborative is about being open to new
information and adaptive is about using
the information you have most
effectively okay so these are the
general principles and then we went
ahead and built a system that satisfies
these properties so at the end of
yesterday we talked some about building
systems Michael Kern's and Curt said why
don't social scientists build more
systems so here we built the system and
I can talk more about why I think more
social scientists don't do this later so
we got some funding from google and we
built this website called all our ideas
org anyone in the world can come here
and create their own wiki survey which
we host for them and it's everything is
free and completely open source and so
this has sort of I think of this as
having to sort of roles one is we get to
actually provide this service everyone
in the world for free which i think is
cool and also we have now a steady
stream of traffic that we can use for
future research so it's a case where
having an impact and doing your research
are mutually reinforcing so what does it
actually look like i'm going to give
tell you a little bit about an example
that we did with Mayor Bloomberg's
office in New York so they wanted to
collect public input on plan YC 2030
this was the city's long-term
sustainability plan so in addition to
other forms of community outreach they
also created a wiki survey so right now
these wiki surveys a lot for a single
question so this is the question that
they pics which you think is a better
idea for creating a greener greater new
york and then you start it off with a
bunch of different seed ideas these are
things like require buildings to make
energy efficiency upgrades and so on all
these seed ideas are limited to all the
ideas in the system are limited to be
140 characters to try to improve the
user experience like we don't want big
manifest is about the nature of City
governance or something so then they
dump all this into our website and we
create a wiki survey for them which has
its own URL so it's all our ideas org
slash plan why see this is the
experience of a user
they come and they see two ideas that
then they click on the one that they
like better a new pair appears and this
process continues again and again
critically at any time anyone can add
their own idea which goes into the
systems the moderator can then approve
that idea then it will appear to future
voters so the role of moderation here is
not to shut off conflicting ideas but
exclude like things like profanity and
so on that the mayor's office did not
want in there also at any time people
can view the results so they can see
which of the ideas are the most popular
so they are scored on a score from 0 to
100 I'm going to tell you now about what
that score is how we do it okay so
that's kind of the motivation and the
user experience yeah
absolutely yeah so once an idea gets
uploaded assuming it gets accepted by
the moderator and most of them are then
it goes into the pool that we choose
from when we present to future users and
one question that comes up a lot is how
do you choose the pairs so for now what
we're doing is something quite simple
it's essentially random it's a little
more complicated than that but for now
you can assume that's random and one of
the things that is part of the design of
this system is that can improve over
time like as we get better and better at
how to choose the pair's there's a lot
of statistical questions about that we
can drop that algorithm in the back end
and this can continue to improve over
time as with the scoring system again
the users don't really need to know or
care exactly how we calculate the score
as we get better and better at doing
that we can drop that algorithm in the
back end as well so it's a system that
sort of set up for continual improvement
as we learn more yep
choices could be that are estimated and
that was about third dubiously exactly
exactly so we completely control the
system so one of the huge advantages of
this approach rather than working with
companies where you have to convince
some project manager what to do here we
completely control this anything that we
want to do we can do we don't need to
worry about shareholders or any it's
like our system and so that create that
means that it's a really an ideal test
bed for research if we can have users
that we can do whatever we want yeah
okay so this is the data that we have so
the data their votes they are nested
within sessions so a session you can
think of roughly as a person but we
don't have any authentication system so
one person could create multiple
sessions that's what I'm going to call
them sessions you see two items and then
you see the item that the person is
chosen yeah
so we have the IP address we actually
don't store that so what we do is we
geolocation we store a hash of that so
this gets into some of the ethical
privacy challenges and i also have a new
appreciation of some of those having had
to try to design a system it can be hard
to be transparent to the users about
exactly what's happening but yeah so we
do not store IP addresses okay so this
is the data that we have this sequence
of votes that are nested within sessions
then this is the target of inference so
this is a matrix where each row is a
session and each column is an idea and
so roughly we want to know how much
everyone likes everything so if we could
estimate this we would know a lot about
let's say the opinions of people in New
York so at least the people who
participated in our wiki survey so for
example theta 1 1 might be how much the
person in session one likes the idea of
free bike racks in Manhattan and theta 1
2 might be how much person one likes the
idea more bus service to the outer
boroughs and so on so this is what we
want to estimate how we're going to
actually estimate this we're going to
assume statistical model so we're going
to make some this is similar to what
Susan was talking about a little bit
we're going to create make some
assumptions about how people vote given
their preferences and then we're going
to make some other assumptions about the
patterns of preferences in the
population and then we're going to do
bayesian inference so I'm going to skip
through the modeling assumptions for now
but they're all in the paper so in the
end you get some posterior distribution
and you take drops from the spicier
distribution and then yep I know we're
supposed to hold questions but I mean at
some point they're used to DJ behavior
right like bikers one more thing to
biker so if there's a consequential
build yeah so this is a good question so
one of the things about strategic
behavior is that this system is much
less susceptible to it than you might
think so a lot so a lot of existing
systems
they allow you to choose which things
you vote on so if you look at a lot of
online polling systems you you like see
a list of ideas you can go there and
upload them so that is very susceptible
to strategic behavior so for example
President Obama used something called
google moderator which is essentially
one of these up voting systems to try to
find the ideas that were most important
to Americans and across a wide variety
of categories they were all related to
the legalization of marijuana and so
President Obama was a little embarrassed
that he because he had pre committed to
answering the questions that come out of
the system and then he had all these
questions about marijuana in the middle
of like the financial crisis and so the
problem was that yet as you can everyone
can know like the marijuana advocacy
organization said everyone go here and
vote for the marijuana thing one
difference here is that with pairwise
comparisons we choose which prompts
people vote on so if you are let's say
your ideas to legalize marijuana in New
York you come here you have to vote for
a long time before that even becomes a
possibility so by us choosing the pairs
we get a lot of statistical advantages
because we can choose pairs that are
most informative to us and we also get
some protection against this gaming
because you can't come here just looking
for marijuana things you have to cast a
lot of other roads so you could say oh
you can come here and you can just vote
randomly until you get to the marijuana
thing and that would be detectable like
we have a whole sequence of votes and we
can see oh this session seems to be
voting very differently than all the
other sessions and then we can
potentially take that session out of the
results ok so we've it's a good gaming
is a big problem with a lot of these
systems so now we've done all this
modeling we have this matrix that allows
us to make all these estimates now we
have a second problem which is that this
is this is pretty much uninterpretable
this is huge it's like thousands of
users by hundreds of ideas it's just a
bunch of number
that are measured on this probit scale
which I haven't talked about so you
can't just like dump this on the mayor's
desk so then we do a second set we're on
the user's screens so then we do the
second step where we reduce this big
matrix into a one dimensional vector of
scores and the score is the estimated
probability that item k beats a randomly
chosen item for a randomly chosen
session so a lot of information gets
lost when you take this big matrix and
you reduce it to this kind of vector
it's all this eras and possibility and
so on but I'm you're just going to do it
anyway because we need something that's
clear and interpretable that we can
present the users the other thing that
may seem strange about this is why
estimate this whole big matrix if all
you're going to do is if all you care
about is these scores right like it's
much easier to estimate the scores than
it is to estimate this whole matrix but
the idea is that the estimating this
entire matrix 1 provides a more natural
way for us to extend the model so right
now we're not using information about
the users we're not using information
about the ideas you want to extend those
in this way and then also there's lots
of other things that we might want to
spit out of this there's lots of other
summary statistics of this big matrix so
if we can estimate this we don't just
get this we get lots of other things to
which we don't have yet but what you
could have in the future okay so let's
see how this actually works in practice
so remember it was part of the city
sustainability plan they have one
question a bunch of seed ideas they
recruited people by outreach through
social media so this is an example of
one of their tweets so this is not a
random sample of people to participate
in this I am very aware of that and but
there's nothing that prevents using wiki
surveys with random samples so again
it's important to separate out the
interview process from the sampling
process okay so they recruited a bunch
of people through social media what
actually happened in terms of the
participation so this you can think back
to that cartoon I had earlier from
Wikipedia so this is a rank or
a plot of the sessions this is the
number of responses and so one person
for example contributed 800 responses
lots of people contributed a very small
number of responses so we designed the
system to be able to be greedy and it
was able to do that people wanted to
participate differentially this also
applies for the ideas that are
contributed by users again you see a
very similar shape most users contribute
who contribute actually only contribute
one idea but some users contribute
multiple ideas so we had about 30,000
responses and about 450 ideas uploaded
so now the results so the x-axis here is
the score remember that goes from 0 to
100 higher scores are better all of the
ideas that are in blue were uploaded by
users so eight of the top 10 ideas we're
uploaded by users so this really to me
shows the value of being open right if
the city has had all the best ideas at
the beginning there's no need to do
something that's open but the fact that
ideas that were uploaded by users scored
better shows that there is of if it
wasn't for this this whole thing would
be kind of not not necessarily worth all
the effort but the fact that these ideas
are uploaded then score well shows that
there is something to be learned from
this process so this is something we saw
over and over again that ideas uploaded
by users scored better than the best
initial ideas and we want to understand
why why was that happening so one of the
things we did is we did interviews with
the wiki survey creators and we asked
them like what are these things that get
uploaded in score well why didn't you
think of them before and so we found
that generally there are two main
categories of uploaded ideas that score
well so one is what we call alternative
framings so these are ideas that the
Creator already had but they're
expressed differently by the users so an
example of this is the top-scoring
uploaded idea keep nyc's drinking water
clean by banning fracking and nyc's
watershed so when we talked to the
people in the mayor's office we said you
know didn't you guys know about fracking
and they said of course we know about
fracking but
we talk about it differently we say
protect the watershed not protect the
watershed from fracking and so but
clearly this is a much more resonant way
of expressing it and I think this is a
general property in the way researchers
design service so like if I have a
survey and I make an answer to my survey
social structure so to me social
structure is like a deep concept with
many hunt you know a hundred year
history of books and that's like an
entire question on someone's general
exam sociologists like what is social
structure so like to me that means a lot
of things to the average user it doesn't
it doesn't have that same connotation
and so it shouldn't be surprising to us
that the way that we express our ideas
as people who have thought about this
problem for a long time might not
resonate with our respondents who
haven't thought about it in the same way
so the second broad category of uploaded
ideas that score well is novel
information so this is stuff that's
actually new and unanticipated to the
users so want to example this plug ships
into the electrical grid so they don't
idle in Port reducing emissions
equivalent to 12,000 cars per ship so
this is pretty interesting so you might
wonder if this is even true and that was
something that the mayor's office
wondered and so it turns out that it's
more like 5,000 cars worship so they
after you know this idea sort of bubbled
up they investigated it and this turned
out to be something that was very
interesting to them so i'm going to i
have a here a little heuristic argument
for why this is always going to happen
so if you do a wiki serve it i will bet
you a beer or whatever people like to
drink in berkeley that the uploaded
ideas will score better than the best
initial ideas and i'm going to briefly
go through this so these are the seed
ideas from New York these are the
uploaded ideas so the y-axis here is the
score so there's two things that pop out
at you one there are many many more
uploaded ideas then there are initial
ideas and the second is that the
variance of the uploaded ideas is much
higher so if your intuition is these
uploaded ideas are going to be garbage
you're right there's a lot of garbage
here but it is high variance there are
some good things there as well and so
generally if you're looking for extreme
outcomes variance plus volume is good so
usually we think of variance as being a
bad thing something we want to remove
but if you care about finding the best
ideas you want to be open to a high
variance high volume data source ok so
we're currently hosting about 8,000 wiki
surveys with about 11 million votes in
total it's been used some by governments
so this is the project by the Brazilian
House of Representatives this is the UN
some social movements like Occupy Wall
Street and Wikipedia and then some
companies as well so take taking a step
back and moving more towards the theme
of this conference in sort of what
social science can do in the future so I
think a lot of social science projects
are very hard it's a lot of work you do
a lot of work you push the rock up the
mountain you get to the mountain get up
to the top and then it's done and then
you guys start pushing the next rock up
the mountain and that's too hard so what
I wanted to try to do is create a
research project that created some
virtuous cycle so that once things you
push the rock up the mountain then it
just sort of starts to roll on its own
and so you can see how the website can
potentially do that so we have users of
the website they help us do research
research helps the website get better
that attracts more users and you can get
this virtuous cycle and then we want to
accelerate this virtuous cycle by
openness so all the code is open source
we make it very easy for you to take out
your data from the website so that you
could take it and write because we only
do a small set of analysis on the
website you may have other ideas for
what you want to do take your data out
and do it that's awesome if what you do
is cool and you think other people would
like it send it to us and we can build
that into the site for everyone so
trying to increase the impact through
openness so just wrapping up you know
the second era of survey research is
basically falling apart
everyone knows this a lot of the move
towards the 30 or sorry research is
driven by fear about the end of this
second era people are like oh I guess we
have to figure out this third era but
what I hope I've showed you today with
the wiki service project is that there's
also a reason to be excited about making
this transition that it's not just that
we should create this third era because
we have to it's also a great opportunity
for us to do stuff that we couldn't have
done before right so this is a really
exciting time and this is a really big
problem not just for academics but for
the world and so in the white paper that
we worked on we talked about sort of
three criteria that these goldilocks
problems should have so problem driven
research so I think there is a real
problem here practical impact I think
there is a practical impact and I think
that social scientists often think of
their impact is happening through policy
makers like let's advise policymakers
about what they should do but we can
also have a practical impact by building
things that are really useful for people
and that was not something that we could
do before because we did not have these
zero marginal cost systems so like the
survey research center at Berkeley there
used to be a survey research center here
that help people do surveys they could
only help people who worked at Berkeley
because it was expensive because there's
people doing stuff and it eventually
actually got shut down because of
funding constraints but now with this
wiki survey is the marginal cost of
another person doing it is basically
zero so we can everyone in the world can
use it obviously we don't do everything
that Survey Research Center used to do
but we can imagine doing that and then
finally a commitment to open this so
thank you
you